السودانيه نترككم مع هذه اللقطات التي
تتحدث عن نفسها
بالتاكيد هذا ما يحتاجه اي شخص بعد ايام
من الخوف لاستمرار الاشتباكات التي تدخل
يومها الثاني عشر في السودان وبعد ساعات
طويله من البحر ومن
المرور بعدد من المناطق التي تجد اشتباكات
وصول الى برلمان في بورتسودان
اذا هذه اللقطات المباشره التي
نبدا او بدانا في هذه الساعه من التغطيه
التركيز الان على عمليات الاجلاء المستمره
من الخرطوم نتحدث هنا عن السفينه رقم سته
كما تابعنا طوال صباح هذا اليوم مع زميل
سلطان السلمي من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
التي استقبلت سفينه تحمل على متنها 2006
مئه وسبعه وثمانين راكبا من ثمن 58 جنسيه
58 جنسيه
1687 راكب منهم فقط 13 راكبا سعوديا
والبقيه كلهم اشخاص من جنسيات مختلفه
ساهمت السعوديه بشكل واضح في نقلهم من
دائره الاشتباكات في الاراضي السودانيه
الى بر الامان في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه سلطان السلمي شكرا جزيلا لك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات